moving to news on the border later today
the Biden Administration will roll out
sweeping new border rules for anyone
seeking Asylum this is a big shift in
U.S immigration policy particularly from
a Democratic president the new rule
requires migrants who cross the southern
border without authorization to prove
that they asked for protection in a
third country if they can't do so they
could be banned from the U.S for five
years and face a felony charge the new
rule replaces title 42 that's a pandemic
era policy that expires at midnight
tonight Manuel bojorquez is along the
border for us in El Paso
the Crackdown in downtown El Paso has
already begun
[Music]
law enforcement and City officials have
been clearing out street encampments
where thousands of Migrant men women and
children have had to sleep for days as
nearby shelters like the Sacred Heart
Church remain a capacity
I can't go back to where I came from
because I could kill my son Gregorio
Felipe fled Guatemala with his
five-year-old son Isidro he said he was
being extorted and was told if he didn't
pay the money they would kill him and
his son he had to leave his three other
kids and wife behind border patrol
handed out flyers like this
urging migrants to check in at border
processing centers or face arrests and
other penalties
many like 23 year old idella Gonzalez
from Venezuela heeded the warning and
stood in line she told us she was
kidnapped by Cartel members at the U.S
Mexico border and held for five days
it's going to be chaotic for a while
while the Biden Administration has been
planning for the end of title 42 States
along the border bracing for a sudden
increase in border crossings or taking
action Republican Texas governor Greg
Abbott sent nearly 600 more National
Guard troops to beef up the border and
in Arizona Democratic governor Katie
Hobbs is sending millions of dollars to
the southern border to support
operations
[Applause]
here in El Paso officials who are
already struggling to house migrants in
shelters are dealing with an influx of
uncertainty and I'm scared just because
of the sheer number of people that could
potentially be involved
you can see the encampment some migrants
here are sleeping in later this morning
the Secretary of Homeland Security is
set to inform the public about the Biden
administration's new policies including
those Asylum restrictions restrictions
the ACLU says will be challenged in
federal court Gail
Manuel thank you